bueno pues aquí en este orgullo esta es
toda esta vía principal que va desde el
castillo de edimburgo desde allí fue
donde ya se empezó a ver esta procesión
un poco más lenta de la llegada de este
cortejo fúnebre de la reina isabel y
estamos a unos 100 metros acá en
realidad del palacio de holyroodhouse
cuando ya se aproximaba pues este
cortejo pasó primero la policía
motorizada y luego por supuesto pues ya
ven pudimos ver en jericó unos momentos
desde una especie de silencio un momento
muy solemne y luego llegaron ya los los
aplausos muchísima emoción en el rostro
de la gente muchos supuestos pues se
grabando este momento con sus teléfonos
este momento histórico un momento un
poco de recogimiento personas incluso
que salieron a sus a sus ventanas quizás
alcanzan a dar un poco los edificios
están a mis espaldas personas que
también salieron allí para vivir este
momento había cientos de personas que
habían llegado aquí desde muy temprano
para tener un buen lugar y poder ver el
paso este deporte fúnebre y ya luego
para se ha despejado pero muchos de
ellos en realidad tenían tenían flores
en la mano y por eso están yendo en esa
dirección que es la dirección de jodi
bieber house porque la idea es dejar
estos arreglos florales en la reja en la
entrada de este la residencia real
natalia que viene para mañana como hacer
el traslado a londres
bueno pues será mañana será un día
digamos el día más importante de lo que
ocurra aquí en el entorno mañana digamos
que todo lo que tiene que ver con toda
esta operación unicornio todavía estará
concentrado aquí en el de un gordo se
espera que sobre el mediodía
12 a 30 local el rey carlos él llegue
aquí a el burgo y luego ya la procesión
que será la salida de el féretro desde
julio verne house hasta la catedral de
sanyo y que está más arriba de esta
arteria que el arroyo mal proceso
comienzo sobre las 2 35 de la tarde
importante será que la familia real va a
ir caminando el detrás de este cortejo
funerario sí que puede ser bastante
digamos un va a ser una procesión un
poco larga hasta esa catedral de sentir
el vendrá luego el servicio religioso y
luego lo que se conoce como digamos ya
una velada de los príncipes eran los
hijos de la reina esa del quienes se
hagan esta velada allí mismo en la
catedral y esto después ya dará y a que
las personas que quieran pues puedan
pasar entrar a la catedral para ya entre
dar ese último adiós a la reina en todo
caso aquí estará durante 24 horas en
esta catedral y sale ya en la tarde ya
caída la tarde del martes cuando el
féretro de la reina isabel ya se ha
transportado a londres finalmente será
un transporte por avión en un avión del
arroyo en host